when is something gonna happen right um
this is a honet see um some lap isn't
even go on a fishing trip whoo and
nothing happened nothing
um they come across some rough waters
but I think about fine
it's about it yeah uh no Jasper comes
back holy shit oh I don't give a shit
about jazz um I uh I like Jasper
Jessica's got issues yeah a little bit
uh well Evans got issues - I thought
that was a man with a hood interesting
when she's like well a mrs. issues
aren't about as much as like it's the
douchebaggery of Jasper and honest man
the man she says uh that she misses
being whew she misses Malachi baby
though there is some abusive
relationship I like story god I'm like
I'm like whoa
did you really just go there like I kind
of miss the abuse not gonna lie well but
it wasn't just that it was the abuse
that a she was taking but B she was also
giving and they're hinting at something
that there's something like no she's
more powerful which is even more messed
up and I don't know it's like she's
becoming more and more intriguing I like
what you gave Jasper the booth I was
like I don't need you anymore so yeah
the fist the the watery fist yes um
that's a so long abusive relationship
sucking well I like that you know she
acknowledges that she did kind of like I
think she knows she's unhealthy for
liking it but then she makes my choices
as I know it's unhealthy even though it
kind of felt good it felt good taking
this stuff out and everything like you
know I can't do it it's just too crazy
and and it's gonna be too bad for both
of us um but I think more for her EW
she's bad person but yeah but she's
saying like you know I may be bad but
you're a monster and I'm just like yeah
what is that history I'm like so
intrigued um III feel it was really
really good I almost want a thee will
die
more into it into the next episode I
almost felt like this could be kind of
like two episodes I want like even more
time going into that but I'm surely you
know the way this show works I only do
it in tomorrow uh Stephen will be going
into a dream about
Lars delivering cotton candy or
something will help him work through
those issues and ten episodes of now
we'll get back to it well something when
we do I see lapis again after wandering
one episode before there was young a
magnetics episode to make us laugh like
the first thing we see is lapis of like
asking you shall resign and an episode
where you know it was a pretty serious
episode a pretty big episode um so yeah
there's something always I like it when
a show can cleverly sort of talk about
that kind of stuff because I feel like
I'm not necessarily talking about like
depression or anything but something
where there is and then we've seen those
people that are kind of attracted to
drama or attracted to something that
they don't like but they're attracted to
it you know there is a vintage yeah it's
like an addiction and they know it's not
good for them and they claim they hate
it and I'm sure they do hate it but they
dramas a total dick look at how the
internet yeah but they kind of love it
too there is like this I I think you say
it's an addiction it's something that's
hurting you but you kind of you know
you're just attached to it um and so I
like the face she does split away from
it pretty fast
um but the same time like maybe a little
bit more diving into that but I'm again
I'm sure there's gonna be much more to
it because they're leading on that there
is a lot more to it um so yeah I like
I'm gonna show canary sings weekend cuz
you could talk about that but can also
be like an abusive relationship it can
be abusive from either side really um so
I kind of feel like there's a couple
different angles you can come at it as
and I like that this show can do I just
assessing it just in the intro just with
we gotta get you on the water I'm like
she fucking fly who gives a shit if she
said I know there well I think it was
more like confronting I guess there was
a part of me though I'm just like who
cares like it's this is a downgrade
got like boating versus flying I
wouldn't I wouldn't my feet wouldn't
touch the ground you know ever if I
could I don't know why it's like we need
to sail why you are disgrace to the name
Walker
we are walkers now I'm flying oh we
would walk Oh using my own two feet like
an animal
hell no oh I would fly like a bird not
an animal yeah um but I would out I'll
be all over it I just Bodie need to get
you on the water we also found out I was
asking the last episode if the father
was still rich and yeah he is I guess he
just likes living out of his van and
renting boats slide flying them now um
it's such an interesting thing that it's
like he's still rich I'm how wondering
where they're going looks like they just
wanted an excuse to just come up with
these various means mm I like float yeah
the car at least the least this went
tightened more to the story proper the
car one just kind of was like they
raised cool yeah moral lesson of the day
though technically you could just like
be on a rowboat ooh or something like
that but they had to be manly didn't
have to be a stuck out there um but a
bigger boat is nice could you can you
know walk around and have fight scenes
on it and stuff like that um so uh ya
know good episode once again leaving it
open for what's you know what how is she
monstrous what do er powers entail and
such um I want to see lapis Unleashed I
like I kind of miss even though the
expressions on her are wonderful I do
kind of miss the water eyes I always
thought those are so cool when like you
look into just see nothing the light
dripping water out it was like surreal
and creepy but I know I the got rid of
it had no and dug specific fetish of the
day no it was just caught her eye
that's remember the one we're like you
know she's just like down like water's
coming out of her eyes alike her mouth
it's just again it was cool or no way
when we know what's in the water as used
in your eyes right or was it both
look into a girl's eyes and see to
myself and and it's so beautiful I start
crying so that's the watery eyes to my
girl I'm totally forgetting what was now
I think there's one episode where water
was coming up I think it was like
reflective eyes is what they were I
think you know that people change
let has changed oh no no it's a good
choice why do you want a regresar why do
you want to go back no I think for a
character I want you to see the eyes and
they're very expressive eyes and they're
well done but it's like yeah I do kind
of remember how cool it was with the I
remember having an argument about this
which I won I'm sure but okay um but we
were talking about like because you were
talking about how you like the mirror
and I said you need the expression of it
and then you were like you're right and
then left such a goth about to move you
like you did because you could handle it
ah that that was right well you know
what I guess uh yes I'll just uh turn
this off here but